foreign
this movie is ultimately about a
homeless man who's willing to do
anything to win back his mother's love
even go into hostile territory
um and I felt that that was something
that was a universal element of what I
had been through in my life as I said
before I spent 10 years of my life
homeless because of my sexuality and
when I joined the Marine Corps you know
I lucked out and then I discovered that
my life had value and meaning because of
my ability to protect other people and I
just felt like that needed to be said
and initially I thought it was going to
be a book and then Chester told me
otherwise
so we were sitting on our couch we had
just finished the pure kids uh Festival
tour
and thank you thank you and
um we had a short before peer kids
caught walk for me that I'd produce an
Elegance at world and direct and direct
it rather and
um
it was between the feature version of
walk for me uh this film and another
film called jazz hands which is like New
Jack City meets pretty woman but instead
of crack cocaine Kane rather it's his
dick that he's selling but you gotta see
that one
but we I was like Elegance you should
for your first feature you should do
something that only you can tell and
take people on a journey that only you
can take them on that's personal to you
and
um the inspection was born in Cisco form
essentially
Elegance can you talk a little bit about
the writing process for you sure
um while this film is 100
autobiographical when it comes to the
lead characters hopes fears and
motivations uh even if the particular
situations are not things that I've been
through when it comes to the
relationship between French and his
mother every one of those words that are
said every one of those Dynamics are
things that I experience with my own
mother
so I think in the autobiographical film
there's kind of a misconception that the
mission is to remember and to write down
like I just remember what happened I
write it down on a page and then I call
Effie and ask her for money and we just
shoot it and that's not what this was
this is really about the essence of
emotional truth I'm not trying to tie
myself up in reams of accuracy but more
so I'm trying to invite an audience into
the skin of a black queer person in the
military myself right so you know when
it comes down to it the writing process
while you know pulled from my life this
is really an exercise of trying to find
that thing that I think everybody goes
through and using the specificity of my
experience to be able to hopefully you
know use my experience to elevate and
uplift audiences who watch this film
was that indicting to yourself like how
many drafts like how long was that
writing process like you had to dig
really deep like did you you know you
start off with vignettes about kind of
moments in your life and then build out
from there well this process of writing
would not have been as fruitful I don't
think the quality of what people are
reacting to would have been a sheet
without folks like Effie Brown
um being a part of that process you know
so I'll let Effie speak about how many
drafts she made me write before I got a
chance
I love you so much
first I just want to say thank you for
that really thank you because I know if
anyone has ever worked with a producer
before when you're getting your drafts
together it could be a little tense you
know but no but you did a really
beautiful job and obviously when I got
to the script you and Chester really
already had it pretty baked in it was
just sort of getting it to I'm gonna
just say production form and just sort
of things and I want to always give you
like a shout out and if there's other
director writers out here how beautiful
you were able to let go of some things
that didn't serve The Narrative of the
story it was true in your story but not
necessarily serving The Arc of the film
so I thought that was it didn't really
matter how many drafts we got to the
draft that needed to be shown but I also
just want to say it's so good to see you
all here I've been a part of film
Independence since Jesus was a baby and
it feels like real talk if you all know
but it's just so good to see you all
here it feels like come coming home so I
just wanted to say that real quick
make sure you picture your ideas nobody
said nothing about that
I mean elegant's already talked about
like writing a script and asking Effie
for money but dial it back a minute and
just say now you have this beautiful
script Chester you know what was that
process starting off like uh you know
Finding Effie
um going through our producing lab a
little bit even can you talk about that
process of getting this project off the
ground sure
um the producing lab was very
instrumental for me
because of uh I like to say I was the
momentum and like the whole thing that
happened to get it to screen essentially
Flo Casey lemons is a mentor of ours a
teacher of elegances at NYU but she
always talks about flow and how things
should flow in your script and how like
it should be like a great song like
everything that you see in the words
everything is just perfect and
the script was great before the lab but
we got notes back from the lab and
um I think
also my mentor was Rebecca Green in the
lab oh shout out to Rebecca who actually
taught me how to put together a movie
essentially like creatively we were
there but the logistics we didn't have
before the producing lab so she actually
taught us how to put together Logistics
and and look at it and hold picture
essentially but we left that lab and
elegance did maybe two more drafts to
the script before it went to Fe and FEI
I met previously at the last La film
independent Gala actually and I like
walked up to Fe and pitched her the
project like I pitched her too but she
doesn't remember that I did sure at all
terrible I totally picture but she
doesn't remember she was just her but
whatever
Chester was like look you're gonna make
this movie and I was like oh okay no and
you know what and then when they came
into my office I was like oh this is my
movie I wonder if they know this because
they were still dating other people but
I had to make sure yeah you guys met at
the project involved Kayla for all of
our PI fellows yeah where Effie was
being honored actually because I was in
the first round that's how old I am yeah
that's right that's all right there you
go yeah but we did that lab and after
doing the lab and getting the script
together and getting the correct budget
together we went into okay without a
little shade did you notice that did you
notice I just want to make sure that you
guys shot that far like we got the right
budget
but we did that and we did the foam
independent Fast Track lab where we took
uh maybe like 40 60 yeah it was 60
Minutes it was 60 meetings in two days
three days three days see it went so
fast
but during that time we dated a lot of
people in La it was like speed dating
and
um right before that we had 40 meetings
at TFI
um Tribeca Film Institute lab so those
are the only two Labs that we did before
we made the movie but or three Labs
rather but um yeah I did I did the Tisch
development lab as well production lab
but um when we Sorry to take it but when
we got to Fast Track it was interesting
because again we we'd met a we'd met
Effie we'd I know my executive at 824 I
went to college with but it wasn't until
we went to Fast Track and the whole town
wanted to make the movie that I was able
to call up 8 24 and be like hey look
you're gonna feel real stupid if you
don't take this movie because somebody's
going to take it off your hands and we
have the steam the momentum to Chester's
Point built up to where it worked and
they were like we're gonna make this
movie
and from independent help with that
momentum essentially
and then you knew that Effie was the one
yeah yes yes well it had to be Effie
because I've you know when I was in film
School
you know black and gay at Tisch which is
like literally the was at times one of
the most lonely positions to be in
um people I mean not people like Effie
was someone who's you know time on
Project Greenlight was inspirational to
me
um someone that I kind of put on my
bucket list of people that like you know
I guess my advice would be to anyone in
an audience who's trying to get their
future made you know really learn the
landscape learn the people who are
making the films that you love I saw
dear white people I saw a real woman
have curves I casted Yolanda Ross in my
first short based off a stranger inside
so you know I I become familiar with
Effie's work and I was like she would
want to make something with me and it
took some time no it took it but it
happened perfect it was perfect perfect
timing
well let's talk a little bit about the
making of the movie
okay get a24 in you've got Effie with
you on the team now
um what was next
location well it's it's a it's a
combination of things you know casting
was really important for us
for me you know authentic casting was of
the utmost I wanted an out black queer
actor to play the lead
um and you know it took some time but
ultimately you know we're in a world
where you know black queer people you
know one out of two of us will be HIV
positive in our lifetimes we're eight
times more likely to commit suicide
eight times more likely to be homeless
and
I just knew that in Jeff Jeremy and I
talk often about what it would mean to
us as teenagers to have had a film like
this right where a black queer person
gets to be the hero and what that would
mean to Future generations of black
queer people so you know to Fe and a24's
credit they supported that vision and we
were able to Cash Jeremy Pope how did
you find him
um I found him on Hollywood like a lot
of people did a Ryan Murphy show I was
also aware of him on Broadway as well I
mean it was Tony nominated for two
different parts in the same year and you
know and then when he got the script
because after Fast Track the script just
went all over honestly we pitched 60
people but I feel like 180 people ended
up getting the script after that pitch
and it got into Jeremy's inbox and then
Jeremy you know made a meeting with me
we spoke and immediately what I
understood was was that we had the
ability together to craft a character
that could speak to this void that
exists in this business of
representation and he's just just
working with the Broadway Talent like
this the discipline the accuracy of
emotional Recreation I need you to do it
this way with a little bit of this added
to it a little bit of this taken away
and he would just hit his Mark every
single time he actually auditioned live
for all of the executives yeah so it has
to give a little bit of a special shout
out to Kim Coleman our casting yes yes
[Applause]
you know she has an Exquisite eye she
does
um so you have Jeremy at what what about
Gabrielle Union at what point did she
come in well fortunately for us Effie
was already working with Gabby on
something so we had kind of a bit of an
Insider helping us to make the
impression But ultimately you know
I guess I could just tell a story when I
was I became a filmmaker who's a Marine
Corps I was stationed in Hawaii making
military films then I got a chance to go
to New York and when I got to New York
my mom was a real you know Troublemaker
she was a shit kicker and she was like
oh you think you a cameraman huh you
think you can make movies
why don't you go buy a camera and go
film your little sister's graduation
from elementary school
so I got to her graduation to film
and none of her classmates even knew she
had a brother
her teachers didn't even know that my
mother had an elder son
and then that moment I resolved to
become a filmmaker
I resolve to become unavoidable
you're not going to ignore me
so you know if you go to the theater
you're going to see my name on a poster
if you turn on TV you're going to see my
name in the credits and someone's going
to ask you is that your son
so Gabrielle Union is a brilliant
brilliant artist I don't ever want to
undermine that but her ability to speak
to my community right I knew for a fact
that if my mother refused to answer my
phone calls somebody was going to tap
her on the shoulder and say Gabrielle
Union is pretending to be you
and she would have to watch
so I'm you know my mom died a few days
after we were greenlit so I have a lot
of gratitude for Gabby for helping to
bring my mother back to life and helping
me to find some closure that I wasn't
able to find with her while she was
living
so with cast in hand we were talking
about where you wanted to shoot this
film where where did you do boot camp I
did boot camp in Paris Island South
Carolina Ura
there's no Marines here no Marines
but yeah I did a boot camp in Paris
Island and um our we ended up shooting
in Mississippi uh and Lieutenant Colonel
Thomas Tuggle who is zaddy like he's
very fine so find him find him he's
married but you might who knows
um but
nonetheless his Police Academy was his
poetic remembrance of his time at Paris
Island in the late 80s so there is this
like spiritual kind of synergy between a
script that I wrote that was my
emotional remembrance of Paris Island
and a physical location that was also
this person's remembrance
um and I'll let these two speak about
the other benefits of the location
elegance and I love photography books
and
uh two photographers in particular that
inspired a lot of the visuals that you
see is Sally Mann who does like Southern
Landscapes and also William eggleton
specifically William eggleton's Cloud
book but we were in Mississippi and we
just went book shopping and we saw this
eggleton book at this bookstore and I
was like Elegance look at these clouds
and they they just look so perfect
almost like a painting and elegance took
the book and gave it to Lockheed RDP who
shot manari and stranger things and was
like I want the clouds to look like this
lucky how do we make the clouds look
like this
and locky took the book and made the
clouds look like that essentially and
Effie can talk to you about the
particulars exactly the particulars and
like you know what's great is when the
creative and commerce can make a baby
and that's what happened in Mississippi
because they had a cash rebate so that
was great and then I'm like so this is
and then so that was one of the reasons
why we were looking at Mississippi we're
looking at Oklahoma and Mississippi and
the film commission we have to give love
to like Nina and tobby yes yes
there you are beautiful there you go you
better say something no no but like they
took us around and um and we found
Colonel Lieutenant Colonel Thomas Tuggle
and um and then with the cash rebate and
actually with the love of the film
commission it was really a no-brainer
the only thing
and I say this and I love Mississippi in
my quick little quicker letter I however
you know what you don't do you don't
shoot there in the middle of summer no
and you don't shoot there in the middle
of summer where your cast is wearing
full-on Marine uniforms and gear and
like we literally that was one of that
that was the biggest I'm sure like the
biggest struggle was the heat like
people were falling out
um so that was the one thing and I have
to take that as the you know as the one
of being like we should go now we got
the money now
we might have should have waited well I
mean the funny thing is we were promised
23 days we actually shot this whole
movie in 19 days because we had a covid
shut down well we had a it was a
combination of covid and heat that shut
us down the first time covered was a
blessing
we're with our family yeah so like just
to be real don't record nothing okay no
but like um but I wasn't okay never mind
it was nothing
just kidding no good no but the covid
you know shut us down in the middle and
then when we picked back up we lost four
days so you know that for instance that
graduation scene that day I had four
different camera teams operating at once
doing pickups from we shot in the
initial 14 days but also trying to get
the details of the graduation itself so
it was but we also on the flip side of
that you got to go to New Jersey and
shot a whole second unit just saying you
know yes
in 19 days okay you know what I'm like
our production reports are going to say
something different but that's okay
summer you were supposed to have 23 days
19 days and then covet hit I'm assuming
you're cast yes of course oh yeah it was
real and crew and crew well that's the
thing like one actor goes down with
kovid but the actor has a hair stylist a
makeup artist a costumer so you'd lose
one but you really lose like five at a
time so by the time we shut down it was
like does the the gaffer know how to do
makeup
go to YouTube figure it out you know
uh how long were you down for before
four months was it four months oh within
four months was it from two months it
was two months it was like two yeah it
felt longer but we edited we did some
editing during that time yeah and just
taking advantage of the time yeah we
didn't lose what was great about this
and this is what I meant by like covet
of course was not a blessing because it
was a very tragic thing that happened
however for us it garnered the time of
like we got to stop and we got to
regroup and we got to come back
in the fall so just to be but like that
was what I meant by like that it was a
bit of a bit of a blessing and we were
able to edit and be able to see the
movie and what was great about that is
that we were able to see that the movie
worked and we got to see like oh oh okay
we need to go back and get that or this
needs to be sort of amped up like we
were able to use the time right sure we
had a when we went to edit that first
time we actually left with a two-hour
cut
so it was really you know our editor was
like we don't want to cut too much you
know we want to leave it there so we can
cut later once we add the other stuff so
the original cut of this one was about
two hours and 30 minutes it sure was
aren't you glad it's not
um did you end up picking up like in
seeing what you in the editing process
during this time down did you add in
anything else when you picked up again
or did you pretty much continue on well
the initial draft of this script was
actually kind of dependent on flashbacks
these kind of memory flashes of French's
time say in the ballroom scene in New
York City
um and
it just was not possible to do while we
were shooting in Mississippi there were
four other movies shooting at the same
time as we were so in terms of like
background talent to even fill out the
graduation or to do a ballroom it just
was not there you know so
um that meant that his a lot of his
interior life that I had planned to do
in flashbacks was no longer we we no
longer had the means to shoot it so one
of the scenes I added was a fantasy
sequence where French
um you know gives head to Rosales you
know um or fellatio for those who are
Latin
um
so
[Laughter]
um
so like you know that's a scene that we
came up with because it was one of those
things where I'm like and mind you that
scene
it was like with the what the Daniel
said earlier about collaborate with the
universe that spoke to me so deeply
because that's ultimately what we had to
do so that day even though we had picked
up even though it was the fall there
were still a lot of just Murphy's Law
happening just people that you thought
would be there were not showing up and
just all sorts of things so I had like a
couple of hours free and I'm like okay
what can I do that could give me access
to French's internal life I have Raul I
have French and everybody else has to be
in hair and makeup right now so that's
the scene we came up with
um you know blowjob is fellatio as well
if you didn't know
[Laughter]
to go in a little bit of a different
direction
I actually I actually want to talk about
a little bit of the writing
um of the script because one of the
things I love so much about the film is
that even in some of the most serious
moments the moments of levity that come
up were just so beautiful and unexpected
and I just like go from heart-wrenching
to smiling and just feeling everything
like that this the scene when they're
all in their bunks and their and then
um and then uh French at the end just
like makes his joke I'm trying to think
like was that all scripted how much of
was improv like how much did you allow
the actors face during the shooting well
you know I come to filmmaking come to
this fiction feature debut through a
documentary experience so documentary
has kind of like softened me to the
notion that anyone who's on camera is a
participant with the director I'm not
dictating to them what they're supposed
to do I'm merely creating a template in
a an opportunity for these artists to
rise to their powers so in that regard
you know I'm not I wasn't I was open to
the idea of improvisation that being
said you know everything that would make
you laugh and this was written into the
script
um and it comes from you know again it's
like I'm trying to synthesize the
emotional experience of what I've been
through in the Marines and anybody who's
been on a film set for more than a
couple of days will tell you intensity
with people with strangers who you
cannot Escape will lead to insanely
funny moments that in any other
situation you would not be laughing at
right and in my experience as a gay guy
I was out in gay when I joined the
Marine Corps I chose to go back in the
closet in a way right but my name is
Elegance
you know pretty much every room I walk
into people assume I'm gay you know and
then you know I so I was kind of like I
just found it funny like the overlap
between this like homo social culture of
the Marine Corps and the gay culture
that I come from like for instance that
uniform inspection I have spent
countless hours being felt up by strange
men because ultimately the physical
fitness is meant to whittle one's body
down into the form of the uniform it has
to fit you a very specific way so and I
got big hips I got a big butt you know
and I would just have guys like come
over and look at his ass his ass is big
right and I'm like he's like rubbing on
it pinching it pulling and I'm just like
man it's I'm not allowed to be turned on
by this
and it's funny
you know so I was just trying to lean
into like that that distance between
where French comes from to where he's
arrived and that notion that like oh my
God I'm different from all these people
but I have so much in common with them
you know that's really where the seed of
the humor in this piece comes from it's
that unexpected connection that human
connection that French is looking for
so we talked a little bit about the
writing of the script and how even this
screenplay changed during the production
let's go into post you start editing how
does the story continue to shift in the
editing process for you
I mean there are so many stages to this
I think the first stage I have to give
credit where credit's due to these two
on the stage with me you know trust I
was going to say
yeah not only is he with you he's with
you 24 seconds yes like I get to go home
yes right
24 7. but um but nonetheless you know I
had that in the first phase of edit of
like just being there with chester
having those weekly meetings with Effie
and just realizing that one I had a
choice to make is this going to be a
two-hour feature dramatic film debut or
is this going to be a 96 minute film
right and it just felt as we were going
through the edit that um and then
orianna so do our incredible editor um
she's just a Titan and a genius in her
own right but um you know it got to a
place where
I read this book in film School caught
in a blink of an eye Edward merch and it
talks about how films are supposed to be
the language of Dreams he even talks
about how when you're showing your film
to an audience very often it's a good
idea to kind of look back and see when
people are blinking because if the
blanks are out of rhythm that'll let you
know that something's not right and that
96 minute pace made all the more sense
right what is it to spend time with a
black queer person in this space versus
again to this idea of recollection
versus emotional truth right like for
instance when I graduated boot camp
there was like a thousand people there
it was a ticker tape parade
we did not have a thousand extras right
so at the end of the day what I
understood about my experience is I
remember feeling close to the people
that I knew
and that being the thing that guided me
through that experience of graduation
you know so in the edit right we're
looking for like those shots you see of
the Shadows right the shots you see of
people executing drill movements this
was how we started to lean on the edit
right to trust the audience to
understand that to fill in the emotional
blanks so that this can be an
interactive experience with an audience
this isn't just me you know
regurgitating what I've been through but
instead an invitation to someone who may
not know what that's like to experience
and I just have to say really quickly to
give you like real Kudos I've worked
with a lot of first-time filmmakers you
were really extraordinary about being
able to hone in your story because that
is so hard to do because a lot of times
filmmakers are so close to it that they
won't and there were very few things
that you stood your ground on and they
were in there left in the movie but I
think you whatever you've done like you
that is a skill that you have that is
really really extraordinary to hone to
something down because not a lot of
people can do that thank you so much
it's true you know what I mean
I just say it so eloquently as well I'm
thinking back from the two and a half
hour cut you had after like for 19 days
down to your 96 Minutes
um okay so you have this film you have a
24 you've survived production a covet
shut down you start submitting to
festivals
In Your Wildest Dreams could you imagine
like imagine that you would be on this
circuit I don't want to sound ungrateful
I'm very very grateful for this
reception but you know my Executives at
Fe and Chester will tell you from the
beginning I told them I want a red
carpet I don't care where we play I got
some fashionable people in this movie I
want to give them an opportunity to show
off on a red carpet you know of course I
I imagined it I dreamed it right I would
say to anyone sitting here you know like
back to my mom you know my mother was
the first person to ever love me
completely she was also the first person
to ever reject me completely
but I know for a fact I would not be
sitting here if it wasn't for her and
you know when I would ever express an
idea to be an artist she would tell me
you're black you're poor you better
dream big because if you aim for the
middle these white people are going to
put you under their foot
that's how I grew up so of course I
imagined it I dreamed it I prayed you
know that's the most beautiful part of
this experience is that I said a prayer
for all of this to happen when I was in
a homeless shelter
I had no idea God had said yes back then
but I work towards it as if that did
happen and now we're here so I'm
grateful for this response I'm not gonna
lie but I believed in it too
I just want to add too
um this year we closed the New York Film
Festival we're the first uh he's the
first black LGBT filmmaker to close the
New York Film Festival in the first
black filmmaker to close it in 60 years
essentially
first timer rather
[Applause]
but
a big thing we talked about before going
to New York is the movie The Battle of
igiers which this movie is inspired by
as well it's like a it's a narrative
film that looks like a documentary
essentially and when it premiered at New
York Film Festival was the Black Panther
showed up and the Black Panthers took
notes of how to start a revolution from
that movie in the audience and the
Revolution was started uh literally a
year later but when we were making this
movie in the process I think about what
the Daniel said earlier about how do you
want the world to respond to it and we
wanted the world to to have a guide on
how to treat their kids that they can
accept or you know
they they can like but they can't or
whether they can love but they can't
like because of the differences that you
know their kids have this different than
a normal person essentially but that was
a big part of that too yeah and
additionally you know this idea of
protecting person to your left and to
your right I think we're in highly
polarized political times at the moment
and I think the left and the right have
forgotten how to listen to one another
and that's the greatest lesson I've
gotten from the Marine Corps and not
even less than the greatest gift I've
got and I have friends literally from
every Walk of Life I have a very close
friend of mine who voted for Trump the
first time and we screamed and yelled
and debated and debated and debated and
the second time he didn't vote for Trump
you know we found a way because because
when you realize that your life is fully
dependent on another person you'll
figure out how to get to the middle much
quicker than thinking that you don't
need that person to your left and to
your right so perhaps you know the
military is an unusual place to find
family but that is one of the lessons in
this film that I want that in terms of
what the Daniels brought up but I really
want people to take away why I think
this film needs to exist is the notion
that you know we can find our human
connection even though we see things
differently and I think that's what we
need right now
[Applause]
so beautifully said I agree with you 150
that's so powerful
um talk to us about so many screens I
mean
you're at the Toronto Film Festival
you're at the New York Film Festival but
we're right beforehand we were talking
about Montclair can you talk about some
of the more meaningful screenings that
you've had oh my gosh I mean this right
here is so meaningful because I mean
it's just like so many different
things like uh bows being tied right now
right when we did Fast Track I mean
Manchester applied to the producing lab
I actually you know I'll tell you guys I
had given up on applying to any laps at
that point I just quit because I applied
to everything with this film and got
told no by everybody with this film
Chester was the one who said I'm gonna
apply even though you said not to and
got us sin when we got in the fast track
I had no idea that it was going to lead
to this none you know I was just okay
Chester you told me to show up I'm gonna
practice my pitch and I'm gonna do the
best that I can you know so this is a
huge moment for me like this is an
incredible like I share this with y'all
it's just amazing
um
but that being said there's been little
there's been moments all the way around
like I mean
I'll go to the Regionals but at New York
Film Festival I went to Columbia
University undergrad I went to school of
the arts for grad film I spent my time
my first time as an artist like making
money in New York I used to photograph
club events you know and then I went
from photographing club events to making
peer kids which I literally made in our
apartment our shitty apartment in Harlem
um you know so to go from those films
and that experience to closing the New
York Film Festival
just
a meeting Martin Scorsese and having
Scorsese want to see my film that just
as a professional was such a huge it's
such a huge moment in my career and my
life as an artist to know that when I'm
committed to something and I believe in
it that this is what I can achieve that
someone like a Martin Scorsese would
care about what I make that was amazing
and then when I get I got to go to
Montclair New Jersey uh for their film
festival and my dad came and my grandma
who's 92 she's not even supposed to
leave the house
she she rolled up with two cousins I'd
never met before
and dropped my dad off to the screen and
my dad rented a tux
and you know my dad had never was not
when I was homeless he was not a part of
my life to have him and I said to him
he's you know it's funny when you have a
result like this you'd be shot how many
relatives just pop up
you know cause an Elegance I've missed
you for the last 20 years where you've
been now that you're a famous director
you know
um you know but I told my dad if you
want to start a relationship with me you
have to watch this film first you have
to know what I have been through uh and
what I am overcoming to open myself up
to this relationship so you know to be
awarded in Montclair New Jersey to have
my relatives there was really really
special to me
um but there's just been I mean I'm
about to go to San Diego to a Marine
Corps base and talk about this movie I
wasn't even allowed to be out and gay in
the Marine Corps so to be able to go
back to a space that is you know granted
you know boot camp has a lot of positive
memories for me because it helped me to
gain a lot of discipline and things that
I needed to get here you know but the
Marine Corps was also a very traumatic
space for me it was hard for me to like
you know get promoted and not have
someone that I love there because when
you get promoted in the Marine Corps
your your loved ones pin you on I
couldn't do that you know so to be able
to go back and to be with my life
partner and to be out through this film
you know it's just it's just crazy it's
incredible you know Lee Daniels is
writing me emails and Catherine Hahn his
friends like it's just it's insane it's
all it's all meaningful and I'm also
acting too I'm in the new Whitney
Houston movie as well I want to dance
with somebody
I got a sad card now
every chance he gets he slips that in
there he's so like I'm in four minutes
of the movie I got my sad card
I just you know you have been such a
force as a producer and have lifted so
many amazing first-time filmmakers in
your career
I gotta bring it back to the producer I
can't help myself but you've lifted so
many filmmakers through the years I mean
and we were just talking earlier about
like what it felt like to see the
success can you share a little bit just
no so
what I said and I actually like one I'm
I love your relationship and like you
guys are my goals so I'm like I want to
have like the ride or die relationship
that you have but one of the things that
I was talking about before you guys got
to dinner was I'm not jaded or anything
like that I love all the experiences
that I've had but what is so beautiful
about this one it's like and I don't
have kids and I was like it's literally
watching you both go through this it's
like watching someone have Christmas do
you know what I mean and like you are so
it's so beautiful to see because he's
not lying he's thrilled you know what I
mean at every Festival he's thrilled but
like oh I get to introduce I'm not that
I'm mad you know what I mean but like
he's so excited to share and like in
both of you together like it's super
oh like this that's what makes this I'm
getting a little but that's what made
this experience for me and being like
just to be able to be a part of your
throttle you don't they don't know it
yet
but I'm not up and down my head I just
want to be I'm not alive
we don't put labels on things right
that's something you kids do now right
you film as a baby
it's amazing
um we have to wrap up but just let's
talk a little bit about aside from
watching you in the new Whitney movie
Yes you want to talk a little bit about
what's ahead more non-fiction work more
fiction work Big Dreams that you want to
put out into the into the world
elegance and I have a production company
called Freedom principle yes yeah
uh we're working on a couple of projects
and wrapping up some deals but uh the
movie comes out November 18th and
um I told a couple of people this
earlier but if you're a filmmaker out
there and you have a short and you take
five friends and you send me the ticket
stubs I'll watch her short
yeah
I'm not gonna offer
offers amazing
you know um in terms of what's next I'm
you know I I kind of have what I call
cinematic dyslexia I can't tell the
difference between a documentary and a
fiction film I think they are just two
different paths to the same end result
so I intend to continue making
documentaries and making fiction films
but really I'm trying to blur the line
between these two forms and if I can
obliterate that line between these two
forms
um and as that goes forward you know
I've got like Chester said we have
projects that are in the offing that we
can't really discuss right now but if
you want to see something soon hopefully
it'll be programmed at a major Festival
soon is
um our movie hellfighter which is about
James Reese Europe a forgotten civil
rights icon from the early 20th century
who's the first black man to play a show
at Carnegie Hall uh the first black man
to serve for his country as an officer
and a foreign battle as the leader of
the Harlem Hell Fighters which
incidentally is also the first behind
that jazz music Ragtime music was
brought to France so we're looking at
his life through the lens of WB du
bois's concept of double Consciousness
which is essentially how black folks see
themselves through white eyes in America
to understand this kind of this
entertainment industry foundational
person and hopefully he won't be lost
after our film people will remember and
care about him so that's that's
immediately next but
there's even more that'll be announced
soon
congratulations we are so happy to have
been part of your journey along the way
thank you for sharing your beautiful
film with us tonight thank you everyone
for joining I hope you had a wonderful
time tell your friends and family to see
the movie yes please theaters yes please
good night y'all thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]